hello everyone in my last video I showed
you a game from a simultaneous
exhibition in 1964 where Fischer played
before on the first move and won a very
nice game but this video I'm going to
show you a game also from the Fischer's
the simultaneous exhibition but it's a
game he lost and the Fischer played 50
opponents in this event
this simultaneous exhibition was
actually held one month after the one
from the previous video I was held in
Hollywood also in 1964 and out of those
50 games Fischer won for 47 he drew two
and lost one game and this is the one
game I want to show you it wouldn't be
fair only to show games were Fischer
wins so but interestingly Fischer is
playing against Don rogozin and Don
roboting is actually the son of human
Rogozin and the human reversing is
famous for losing one game to frank
marshall the strongest american player
of the previous era so it's kind of
interesting that his father played
against the strongest american player of
that era and now he himself is playing
against Bobby Fischer the strongest
American player of this era but let's
see the game Bobby Fischer is the white
and the donor goes in his black and yeah
I will put the link to the game that his
father played against Frank Marshall in
the description of the video so you can
check it out
it's a very nice game Fischer plays d4
we have c5 by dawn Knight to f3 d6 d4
see captures on d4 nice capture stunt d4
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now a6
denizer Sicilian we have Bishop to c4
it's kind of a Fischer favorite move
east six Fischer castles Bishop to e7
Fischer plays Bishop to b3 we have
castles f4 Queen to c7 Queen test three
by Fischer Knight to c6 Bishop to e3
and now rogozin plays Knight after sandy
for Bishop casters on d4 and v5
preparing to develop the light square
bishop and the official push is ePHI and
this e 5 move kind of seems that it's
threatening to capture the night and
also the Rokan a it but it's really not
don't simply place
chapters on e5 and if if Fischer was
were to capture this rook for example
Queen captures an a8 you'd get he
captures on d4 capturing the bishop and
now attacking the knight and after the
nice moves
simply Bishop to b7 only move for the
queen is going to a7 and now Bishop to
c5 try to the Queen so of course after D
captures after D captures on e5 f is
replace F captors on e5 and now Rogozin
plays Bishop to b7 attacking future
screen but this is also a very well
known line so Fisher simply captures the
knight he captures and f6 and sacrifices
the Queen for three pieces we have a
Bishop captures on f3 s captures and e7
threatening to capture the rope with
check so the pawn has to be captured
Queen captures on e7 and our captors on
f3 and let's see the disposition okay
black is a pawn off of buzz Fischer has
three pieces for the Queen three minor
pieces so we have rook a to d8 Bishop to
e3 protecting the wish of Queen to b7
rook a to f1 doubling up on the F file
we have a rook the rook from F to e8
nice te 285 and now the Fischer played
this Knight to e2 move to you know to
get his knight into the attack and also
to play c3 to make room for this
LightSquared bishop so he does he play
c3 and now Rho goes in place a very
strong move he plays a queen 34
centralizing the Queen and well his
position is pretty cool now and Fischer
actually he wants to capture on f7 but
he can capture now because his bishop
will be hanging so Fischer kind of
thinks that this is winning for him and
he plays Knight to g3 kicking the
clean-out of e4 and then preparing to
capture on f7 next move
so R goes in place Queen to g6 and of
course now Fischer captures the rook
captures on f7 and this is this is a
wonderful move this is a complete
blunder and the Fischer miss is actually
a four and this Bishop is now trapped
the
has nowhere to go the C 2 square is
covered by the Queen and the Fisher
probably overlooked that after Bishop to
Bishop 2 D 1 guru can simply capture it
through captures on D 1 because after
disrupt captures it's back then well
white will probably have to play real
captures on g7 and after Queen captures
rook captures here and the black will be
simply out too much material so yeah
efficient kind of missed this a for move
and this is very interesting because
from a very young age Fischer should
show some tendencies it was getting his
bishops trapped this kind of reminds you
of the first game against Spassky in
their World Championship match in
Reykjavik where he snatched death h2
pawn and got his Bishop trapped in the
end game but ok it happened you know he
did lose only this one out of 50 games
so has Bishop to see to buy Fischer
Queen captures on c2 and now Fischer
plays Knight to h5 Canada Perez this
g7 bond but after playing this move
Fischer also resigned so yeah I mean
there's really nothing for whites to
hope for here black can seem to play a
rope to f8 and even if white captures
here this is still completely winning
for example I don't know rope captures
rook captures and well there's really
nothing to play here for blood for white
so yeah a very nice game and it seems
kind of poetic that that eundel rogozin
was able to to kind of avenge his father
for losing that game against the
strongest American player Frank Marshall
even though what we did blonde or a
piece there but you know it doesn't
matter what what people remember is that
the Fischer 140 47 games he drew too and
that he did lose one game so yeah that's
it for this video I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and if you're a
recent subscriber to this channel I will
also put a link to with the playlist of
all the other videos so you can you know
enjoy them as well so and that's it
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon